at first glance this bus seems like any
other in the German city of Braunschweig
except at this stop in the city centre
the bus lines up with a plate in the
ground and charges using a magnetic
field the driver doesn't need to get out
to plug a big thick cable into a
charging dock then remove it from the
dock and store it back in the bus
instead the bus charges of the press of
a button don't I uh stupid I'm icing
simple enough talking
buses can charge at the depot overnight
or even four minutes and seconds at a
time while passengers board at two other
stops how far a bus can go on a single
charge is well researched if the bus
sticks to its route no problem but not
scientists at the automotive research
center in college bike want to find out
how to bring induction charging to cars
for that they need a widespread network
of charging points for example at
traffic lights
the apothem skinnies on average you can
expect cars to stop for about 30 seconds
of traffic lights it's not the same for
every type of vehicle but for those
which don't they can charge at the next
red light so they'll have the power they
need a car can only store about 1/10 of
the energy a bus can hold outside of
cities fewer traffic lights would mean
fewer chances to charge another
implementation that we're considering is
not just to have charging points but to
have a constant magnetic induction in
the road we'd have an extensive primary
coil installed in the street so that
cars can get the power to drive as far
as they need to permanent magnetic
fields and roads are still a long way
off but individual charging docks like
these can be installed quickly and have
an upside for the city scape when
compared to tracks and overhead cables
this is it's an advantage because you
can't see it you've a load of around 200
kilowatts but you can't see anything
except what we're standing on now a
small charging plate that's what I
forgot Rodina Monica and Laura Plaza 3
buses are currently using induction
technology in pouch bike and two more
are set to take to the streets by the
end of the year and next year three cars
will take the tech to taxi customers
you